An impenetrable, physical, tall, powerful,
beautiful, southern border wall.
Should we build the wall?
They're bringing drugs, they're bringing crime,
they're rapists
and some, I assume are good people.
Donald Trump recently traveled to the US/Mexico
border near San Diego
to tour prototypes of the big beautiful wall
that was the centerpiece oh his presidential campaign.
Trump supporters came out to express their
enthusiasm.
Why do you support the wall?
It's like, if you had a kennel, with dogs,
I'm not saying that we're all dogs or anything like that but,
are we going to let them all run in the field?
Trump has requested 25 billion dollars just
to build the wall
and independent estimates put the price tag
even higher.
Trump's saving a lot of money so, nobody should
be complaining about the cost.
Everything that comes with illegals and drugs
and other things, that's also expensive.
Annual maintenance would run at least hundreds
of millions of dollars
on top of the billions already being spent
to expand border patrol personnel and technology.
Mexico will pay for the wall.
Actually it won't.
I'm not going to pay for that fucking wall.
Which leaves american taxpayers on the hook.
There's a lot of people here who are criminals,
drug dealers, gang members.
We've seen example after example of people
killing people and then nothing's happening.
But there are good people too,
so we also have to make sure that we're cracking down on the bad
rather than the good.
Do you think that there's any merit to the
argument
that instead of spending, you know, 25 billion
dollars on a wall
we could better use those resources if we're
actually just targeting the bad actors.
This is an investment on it's own, any investment's
gonna cost money.
And of course the initial investment's gonna
be huge.
As a border patrol agent, I can tell you that
walls do work.
The US has erected hundreds of miles of fencing
and other barriers in the last 30 years,
more than quintupled the number of border
patrol agents on the ground
in addition to installing high tech sensors
and cameras and using military drones to patrol
and yet coyotes and drug cartels have out-innovated
authorities
using tunnels, planes, drones, ships, catapults,
car ramps, and even specially built submarines.
So how would this new wall be different?
You're dealing with people who will find a
way around it,
but I think one of the most powerful things
we can do is create deterrence.
You build a 30 foot wall, you need a 31 foot
ladder, right?
Like, what do you say to people that say that?
They got to come over the other side.
What about if they have a rope?
I'm in favor regardless of what fence, there
needs to be razor wire,
but they're staring at a wall of razor wire,
they can't cross.
Something concrete or also you're not having
people digging holes under the wall either
because people can dig holes under walls too.
It doesn't have to solve all our problems
but we have to start moving towards a solution
and I don't think you can have it without
a wall.
But would a new physical wall actually accomplish
what supporters hope for?
The majority of unauthorized immigrants to
the US don't walk across the border.
They show up with temporary visas and then
overstay them.
And these days more Mexican migrants have
been exiting the country than coming in.
This is the land of the American dream and
we want people to come in here.
But we want people to do it the right way,
like my family did when they came from Mexico and Cuba.
But for Mexican immigrants getting a visa
is nearly impossible.
In 2018 the quota is just 25 thousand people
and there are nearly 1.3 million on the waiting
list.
I don't want our country to change to the
point where it is not what it is now.
You're from Iraq, right?
So people who are pro wall, pro Trump, might
say
'well people from Iraq are changing the nature
of our country.' right?
So do you worry if we put caps on legal immigration
that people like you
who are immigrating and trying to do the right
thing won't have that opportunity?
Ok, you gotta care about American citizens
first,
yes there is a lot of people in my original
country that want to come to the United States,
but I'm an American right now, it's, you gotta
look at what for the American people first.
Ironically, expanding fencing and reducing
guest workers over the last few decades
has led to more unauthorized immigrants staying
in the US.
Because the barriers didn't stop entrance,
but they did raise the cost of going back over the border.
An exhaustive study by Princeton sociologist
Douglass Massey
concluded there are now over 5 million more
illegal residents
than there would have been if policies under
Ronald Reagan had been maintained.
Rather than talking about putting up a fence,
make it possible for them to come here legally
with a work permit,
and then while they're working and earning
here, they pay taxes here.
And when they want to go back they can go
back, and they can cross,
and open the border both ways.
Only about a third of border land is owned
by the federal government
with the rest split between states, Native
American tribes and private land owners.
There's people along the border that would
have to have part of their property taken,
do you think that, are you concerned about
that?
I'm not concerned about it, maybe the ranchers
might be.
Right there you're all of a sudden going to
that land grabbing thing.
It would require some takings, right?
Innocent Americans would be caught up in immigration.
It's the art of the deal, you know?
It's, you know, people want change, people
want change.
Building a wall along the entire 2 thousand
mile border also poses practical challenges.
A double barrier, like those that already
exist near San Diego and around the Rio Grande
needs to be porous so that flood waters can
escape and Americans can access their land.
If we can build the atomic bomb in in three
or four years we can build a fence.
What year was the wall of China built?
There's a lot of walls around the world.
But Trump's proposed wall presents unique
challenges.
In a world in which most illegal immigrants
don't walk across the border
and not a single terrorist ever has,
in which small businesses rely on immigrant
labor
and in which average Americans can be hurt
by increased prices
or violations of their civil liberties
does it make sense to spend tens of billions
of dollars on this particular wall?
It's at least a symbol that we are willing
to define where our land ends
and, you know, Mexico begins.
America needs to be America first like, point
blank.